esta camioneta que está a mis espaldas
es uno de los testimonios de los días
más duros que vivió la ciudad de jarc it
is atención está prohibido el paso a
civiles y es que nos encontramos en la
zona de sal típica más al norte de la
ciudad de kharkiv y uno de los lugares
sino el que más fue atacado con mayor
insistencia por las tropas rusas muchas
de las edificaciones si no todas
sufrieron daños a mis espaldas se puede
ver como algunos de los apartamentos
quedaron quemados y es que las
autoridades de esta ciudad que es la
segunda más importante y más grande de
todas o crean y han asegurado que al
menos 5.000 edificaciones civiles fueron
destruidas o quedaron dañadas durante
las primeros meses cuando las tropas
rusas estuvieron aún más cerca de la
ciudad esta ciudad sigue siendo atacada
en la mañana de hoy odiamos varias
explosiones lejos pero si hoy han y en
los últimos días han habido explosiones
en áreas civiles como la mayoría de
estas ataques a la población de jarquín
pasada morían seis personas en uno de
los tantos ataques que se dan en esta
ciudad que sigue resistiendo algunas de
las personas que viven en esos edificios
y que por meses vivieron en los sótanos
los siguen haciendo en las noches pero
aún así siguen en sus apartamentos y se
han negado a ir o ir porque ellos dicen
que no tienen a donde ir y muchos de
ellos son personas mayores